[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
Eric, welcome to "Coffee
With a Googler."
Tell us all about yourself.
ERIC SEIDEL: Yeah.
So I've been at Google for--
wow, like a decade now,
mostly working on the web
until about three
years ago when I
helped start the
Flutter project, which
is now what I work on.
And I've been writing
code most of that time.
Although a couple of
years into Flutter,
I switched from
coding all day to now
I lead the engineering team.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
what's it like changing
from coding all day to being
an engineering manager?
Remembering that our audience
are primarily developers, so--
ERIC SEIDEL: It's been
a wild ride, mostly
because Flutter
has been exploding,
usage inside and
now outside Google.
And that's been fun.
And it's fun to just help
people get stuff done.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now,
you've had a background
in a lot of web and
particularly in rendering.
And how has that helped
you with building Flutter?
ERIC SEIDEL: Yeah.
So I've worked on rendering
systems for 10, 15 years now--
again, mostly on the web.
And that's how we ended up
starting Flutter, is that we--
I feel like that's
where my leverage is.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
like that expression--
where my leverage is.
I have to remember that one.
ERIC SEIDEL: Yeah.
We just wanted to do
something better for Mobile.
LAURENCE MORONEY: How
did Flutter start?
ERIC SEIDEL: Well,
that's a bit of a story.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
My favorite kind.
ERIC SEIDEL: So I used
to work on Chrome.
And I was on the Chrome
team at the time.
And we were working with
some hard problems trying
to get certain parts of the web
to really be nice and smooth.
And for whatever reason,
we did this experiment
for a couple of weeks
where we decided
it was going to be OK to break
compatibility with the web.
And we--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thankfully
it was only an experiment.
ERIC SEIDEL: Oh,
just an experiment.
But with that
restriction removed,
we started removing things,
all these old compatibility
supports for all
these obscure websites
that the vast majority
of us never go to.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Or maybe
they don't even exist anymore,
because it evolves rapidly.
ERIC SEIDEL: And we
just kept removing
and removing and removing.
And at the end of
a couple weeks,
we ran our benchmarks again.
And obviously, this wasn't
quite the web anymore.
It couldn't render all the web.
But it was 20 times faster
on some of the benchmarks
we cared about.
And we were like,
there's something here.
And so we kept digging.
And from that, we started.
And it probably took us
about another year of digging
before we realized we just need
to write a whole new thing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it's like
now-- tell me what Flutter is.
What is it all about?
There's a lot of
misunderstandings
and misconceptions, and I
know I've had many of them.
So assume I know nothing, which
is a pretty safe assumption.
So tell me about Flutter.
What is it?
ERIC SEIDEL: Flutter is a way
to write for iOS and Android
from a single codebase.
And we try to make
that fast and easy.
And we make a bunch of choices
in that space to try and do
some awesome things there.
For example, we--
Flutter is a full stack.
We talk all the way
down to the GPU and CPU.
We talk straight
to the hardware.
We made a bunch of choices
early on around making
custom very easy.
So we have a very
layered approach.
You can take as little
or as much as you want.
And then finally,
the third thing,
we have a bunch of
investment in tooling.
So that's part of how we
make development fast.
We have things like
a developer cycle
that's less than a second.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Tell me about that.
Less than a second from--
so when I save my code
to actually running it?
ERIC SEIDEL: Yeah,
running on the device.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
How does that work?
ERIC SEIDEL: Well,
so obviously, we
have to use the iOS
and Android tools
to get the code onto the
device in the first place.
But once it's there, then
you just edit your code,
and you hit Save.
And we have this thing
called Hot Reload
where we inject the new code
into the running Flutter
system.
And it just updates.
You don't restart your app.
You don't change your
place in the app.
The code just changes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
I've been a mobile
developer for a while,
so building on various
mobile platforms.
And it's always like,
compile, deploy, wait
for it to boot up,
wait for it to execute,
wait for the debugger to
start only to find out I
left out a semicolon
or something like that.
So that can be minutes in
some cases with some images.
So by cutting that to a
second, what kind of things
are you seeing, the impact
that has on developers?
ERIC SEIDEL: Oh, it's
totally changed the way
we see people develop inside
Google, those who use Flutter.
Some teams we've
seen just literally
sit with our designers.
And they talk about
painting their app to life.
We have-- one of our
founding principles--
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see
Bob Ross as you say that.
ERIC SEIDEL: Totally.
Lots of little treats.
But you watch these
teams, and again,
they just hot reload,
hot reload, hot reload,
and their app comes to life.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
That kind of iteration is
made possible by the fact
that you have Dart as
the programming language?
Is that right?
ERIC SEIDEL: That's right.
We do use a programming
language that
hasn't seen a lot of
usage outside Google yet
but actually gets quite a
bit of usage inside Google,
and that's called Dart.
And we're the first
mobile adaptation of Dart.
And Dart gives us things
like this hot reload.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
one of the confusions
that I often hear,
particularly when we say, hey,
we have a platform for
building for multiple devices,
is that it's a thin veneer
over a web platform.
But Flutter is something
very different, right?
ERIC SEIDEL: Not at all.
That's right.
So Flutter, again, we go
straight to the metal.
We have a custom runtime that
we've built from the ground up.
And we use some best
in breed technologies
from the rest of Google.
We use Skia, which is this
rendering technology that's
used in Chrome and Android
and a few other places.
And we use the text rendering
system, or parts of the text
rendering system, from Android.
And then we also use, of
course, Dart, the start runtime.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So what does
a Flutter application look like?
I assume I'm not compiling
a .app or a .apk.
So what will it look
like if I'm going to iOS
or going to Android?
ERIC SEIDEL: So
actually, you are.
So a flutter application
is just an iOS app or just
an Android app.
Flutter provides, actually,
a view, a Flutter view.
And most people use
those full screen.
And then we paint every single
pixel you see on the screen.
But you can use Flutter
view alongside all the rest
of your Android views
or your iOS views.
So yeah, you retain
full control.
And you can write as much
Java, or as much Kotlin,
or as much Swift, or
as much Objective C
in the rest of your application
and then share as much
as you want between
with Flutter.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So even
if I have an existing app,
I can start then improving
that using Flutter?
So it doesn't have to be--
ERIC SEIDEL: You don't
have to start Greenfield.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
And one of the things I noticed
when I was browsing the Flutter
website is that there's a whole
bunch of controls as well.
So these look--
and I was wondering
if that leads to maybe some
web confusion because they're
very web-like controls that you
can have as add-ons to Flutter.
ERIC SEIDEL: So some of that
comes from the inspiration
from the web.
So a lot of my team
started on the web.
I used to work on the
web for many years.
Our current tech lead, for
example, wrote the HTML5 spec.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Your tech
lead wrote the HTML script?
OK.
ERIC SEIDEL: There's some
deep roots in the web.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Definitely.
ERIC SEIDEL: But yeah, so we
do share some of the same nouns
and verbs, as the web does.
We have something
called flexbox.
And so it should feel
very familiar to people
coming from the web,
but it is not the web.
The technology core
is not the web.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it really
feels like a best of both.
ERIC SEIDEL: We hope so.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
say I'm a developer,
and I'm either a mobile web
developer building native apps
in iOS, Objective-C, Swift, or
in Android in Java [INAUDIBLE],,
or maybe I'm a mobile
web developer--
what advice would you give
me in how to get started
and how to get productive
really quickly with Flutter?
ERIC SEIDEL: Sure.
So obviously, all our
docs start at flutter.io.
That's our domain.
But there's also a ton of
YouTube content out there,
people doing tutorials.
LAURENCE MORONEY: One
of the other things
was I know you've just
released the beta.
ERIC SEIDEL: That's right.
Just this last week,
we announced beta
at Mobile World Congress.
We're now starting
to ship regular betas
that we've vetted
further so they're
nice and stable for your usage.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
And even though you've been an
alpha and just gone into beta,
I know lots of people have been
using Flutter, and lots of apps
have been built with Flutter.
Do you have any
particular favorites?
ERIC SEIDEL: So the
biggest name that folks
know is the Hamilton for
the "Hamilton" musical.
That app was written
in Flutter last year.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm a
total fan of that musical.
I'm going to start
singing it in a moment
now that you've mentioned it.
I have songs going
around in my head.
ERIC SEIDEL: And Google
has released a few apps,
and there's a few
more on the way.
And the community, again,
is just starting to explode.
We've seen hundreds of
apps already launched
at the Play Store, and
again, lots more [INAUDIBLE]..
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now, I know you've
had some really fun
scenarios of things
that people have
done with Flutter.
I've heard of-- what
was it, some designers
taking a look at award-winning
designs and then redoing them?
ERIC SEIDEL: So I know the
story you're talking about.
But yeah, one of the fun
things that we see with Flutter
is that we have, as
a founding principle,
that you should never have
to say no to your designer.
You should be able to do
anything the phone can do,
anything your designer
might want to envision.
And so we see
people testing this.
And they go to these
design websites,
and they find the winning
design of that day
or the winning
design of that month.
And they're like, can
I do that in Flutter.
And most of these designs have
never been done before-- never
been implented for iOS,
never been for Android,
and they do it on Flutter.
And one person in
particular in Spain--
Serge, Serge [INAUDIBLE].
LAURENCE MORONEY: Not our Serge?
ERIC SEIDEL: Not our Serge.
And did a tutorial series
where he took one of these,
and he built it up.
And it's just neat to see
people doing that kind of thing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So again, if I want to get
started, it's flutter.io?
ERIC SEIDEL: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And the
beta is now available.
So even if you're
a developer who's
played with Flutter
before, and maybe it
wasn't for me because
it was in an alpha,
you get to try the beta.
ERIC SEIDEL: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
flutter.io, download the tools,
and get started.
Cool.
Well, thank you, Eric.
It's been a lot of fun.
And thanks, everybody,
for watching this episode
of "Coffee With a Googler."
If you have any
questions for me,
or if you have any
questions for Eric,
and if you want to know more
about Flutter, please just
leave them in the
comments below.
Thank you so much.